Ford Motor Company President and CEO Alan Mulally...
...set the tone for the 2010 Washington auto show.
I'm Alan. I'm from Ford, and I'm ready to take care of your car needs.
Mulally announced a $400 million investment...
...that he said would make Ford's next generation Explorer 25% more fuel efficient.
Because of our size and our scale, when we make that kind of fuel efficiency,...
...and we put it in across the entire product line,...
...we make a significant improvement in fuel mileage and CO2 reduction.
Ford is coming off its first profitable year since 2005.
The company expects hybrids and electric vehicles to make up 20% of its fleet by 2020,...
...up from 3% today.
That interests Cynthia Smith from Potomac, Maryland.
I would like to support some sort of alternate energy option.
But she's not convinced that she would buy the much anticipated Chevy Volt,...
...a General Motors electric car that runs 64 kilometers...
...before a gas powered generator kicks in to extend the range.
If I'm gonna take a long trip,...
...I just plain would not buy a car where I was 100% limited...
...to an infrastructure that isn't there yet.
I'm not ready to make that kind of a leap.